retour à cannes depuis quelques minutes
s'est achevée la remise des prix sur la
scène du palais des festivals isabelle
huppert présidé cette cérémonie de
clôture voici le palmarès choisis par le
jury philippe lefait
messieurs mademoiselle isabelle huppert
une chose est certaine en tout cas c'est
que le monde change des images le cinéma
se nourrit de réalité même si
heureusement il la transforme cette
réalité et quelquefois la transcende le
palmarès de ce 51ème festival est donc
signée par un jury de dix membres
emmenés par le président scorsese
la cuvée 1998 comme attendu est
excellente
deux prix spéciaux du jury
la classe de neige de claude miller qui
met en scène un enfant secret et fragile
qui découvrira à la montagne une vérité
encore plus dur et festen de thomas
vinterberg qui incarne la nouvelle vague
danoise on y refuse désormais dans la
chasse au superficiel le cinéma d'antan
festen c'est une querelle de famille
brut de décoffrage comme envoya nous a
rejoint sa demande comme il ya un petit
peu dans la lune il a oublié son sac
dans la voiture alors son père leur
apportera demain mais pour ce soir il a
besoin d'un pyjama donc qui peut lui en
prêter trop longtemps qu'ils se taisent
pris dans telle autre affaire prétention
masculine décerné à l'unanimité
c'est comme my name is you pour
l'interprétation masculine c'est dans le
film de ken loach une valeur sûre
la récompense pour le travail
remarquable d'un acteur qui incarne un
alcoolique dans sa résurrection
prix d'interprétation féminine experts
quand elodie bouchez et natacha régnier
la vie rêvée des anges un premier film
d'erick zonca 41 ans un premier long
métrage l'itinéraire croisée de deux
paumés deux actrices évidente la brune
elodie bouchez et la blonde natacha
régnier action à lille un film en 16 mm
pour un petit budget de 8 millions de
francs
c'est combien de pièces trois par jour à
mille milles et un et ça fait longtemps
que les couturières fois à dijon
il s'est finalement benini qui signe ici
le das couronné par cannes
la vie est belle si belle que cette
comédie de belloumi s'achève en camps
d'extermination le film déjà un triomphe
en italie voisin cloud confronté à la
shoah qui veut préserver un enfant même
s'il tourne le dos au réalisme benigni
fait référence à primo levi qui a décrit
autrement l'absurde benini revendique
l'horreur et la fable est ici au resto
et babouche de loyer il aurait des
portes à riposter ça ne nous fait plus
attendre qui a gagné
cette palme d'or pendant un temps limité
tout l'été n'était et on joue
ainsi donc que l'éternité et un jour
palme d'or parce qu'un jour theo
angelopoulos a vécu les dernières heures
de jean marie à volonté sur un autre
tournage il a eu l'idée de ce film sur
la vie juste elle celle d'une seule
journée
une éternité
un petit arriverait te rappeler ce jour
souviens toi que je les regardais tous
les yeux que les caries sud est où ton
can 1998
on l'attendait la vie est belle comme
une éternité
parce que derrière